bonjour bienvenue sur diagonale tv
aujourd'hui une émission sur les grands
champions sur en particulier un dans
champions mais elle nage d'or avec
jérôme gouffre un bon jour jérôme
bonjour stéphane alors très grand
champion que son âge d'or argentin mais
en fait d'origine européenne
oui les polonais d'origine juive
polonaise communauté juive européenne
donnait énormément de champion d'échecs
dans l'entre-deux-guerres et c'est le
cas aussi de nash dorff dont le premier
prénom n'est pas miguel mais michel en
polonais ouais je me
ne lancerait pas dans la prononciation
du polonais c'est très compliqué oui
mais effectivement c'est un grand
champion l'extraordinaire longévité
il a joué le championnat d'argentine
jusqu'en jusqu'à 81 ans il est né en
1910 à l'époque où la pologne d'ailleurs
n'existe pas on parle de polonais mais
on parle d'un peuple d'une ethnie mais
on parle pas véritablement d'une nation
puisque la pologne est intégrée à
l'empiré russe à l'époque et la
communauté juive notamment il subit de
nombreuses vexations voir des pogroms
les juifs de pologne ont été accusés de
l'assassinât d'aller d'une star
alexandre ii en 1880 et ça a donné lieu
à des répression très violente en 1906
il ya même eu un pogrom à bialystok en
pologne qui a fait une centaine de morts
les parents de xavier tartas cover le
champion qui s'est exilé en france par
la suite sont eux-mêmes mort dans un pot
grand et le petit miguel nash dorff une
chaîne l'âge d'or menée dans cette
communauté qui vit entre répression et
période de tolérance religieuse
la situation s'améliore une fois que la
pologne devient un pays indépendant
après la première guerre mondiale
puisque le régime autoritaire de piste
du ski donne quand même une certaine
liberté religieuse à la communauté juive
de pologne n'accordant qui il se
retrouve en argentine alors ils se
retrouvent pas tout de suite en
argentine parce que il commence à jouer
aux échecs en pologne et pour le compte
de la pologne
il finit 2e du championnat de pologne je
crois en 1931 donc dans le dès les
années 30 il est déjà un très fort
joueur à l'échelle nationale et après
avoir fini sixième au tournant de
margate en 1939 il est sélectionné pour
représenter la pologne aux olympiades
qui vont se dérouler en argentine
oui il se rend donc en argentine avec
l'équipe de pologne en 1939 et le temps
d'arriver le temps que la compétition se
déroule et bien l'armée allemande et
l'armée
rouge ont envahi la pologne donc il
apprendre la nouvelle halle à l'invasion
de la pologne alors qu'il jouait aux
échecs aux olympiades en argentine ça
n'empêche pas de faire un excellent
résultat au deuxième et chic et puisque
il doit totaliser une douzaine de
victoire sur cette partie et 4 nuls il
décide avec une partie de l'équipe
polonaise de rester au moins le temps de
la guerre en argentine puisque il serait
victime de persécutions à double titre
on en polonais en tant que juif est
évidemment s'il retournait en europe
il ya un énorme souci à ce moment là qui
est bien compréhensible c'est que sa
famille restée en pologne
donc pour leur donner des nouvelles bien
il donne une grande simultanées contre
40 adversaire pour en espérant que cette
nouvelle va être reprise dans les
journaux européens et que ses parents
pour avoir comme ça par ce biais des
nouvelles de lui après la guerre une
décide de rester finalement en argentine
oui il aura fait le bonheur de
l'argentine d'ailleurs parce que cc
c'est un des joueurs qui a le plus
marqué sans doute les échecs sud
américain avec peut-être making après un
peu plus tard mais qui a beaucoup fait
pour populariser le jeu et le développer
que ce soit en argentine au brésil enfin
dans toute l'amérique du sud et qui
faisait la fierté de désavantage est
qu'ils sont quand même une un peuple à
ses fans de jeux de chine aic et
aujourd'hui encore nageurs restent une
référence là bas rhin où il a été
littéralement adopté lui même a changé
son sa nationalité son prénom il est
devenu mondial l'âge d'or dong égal
comme l'appelaient les argentins dont
qui sont qui sont traqués et qui ont été
très fan de d'échec des cette période là
on a eu d'autres champions venus
d'amérique du sud comme chaussée raul
capable en cas oui le cubain mais il
fait partie de cette de cette galaxie de
joueurs sud-américains très brillant il
a été adopté
d'autant plus facilement qu'en argentine
eh bien il ya de nombreux européens qui
sont venus s'exiler que ce soit au 19e
siècle ou au 20e siècle
alors c'est une chose assez intéressante
au plan historique c'est que les terres
du nord de l'argentine de la patagonie a
été occupé par des indiens à l'origine
qu'ils ont été chassés par le
gouvernement argentin et le gouvernement
argentin pour mettre en valeur ses
terres a accueilli à la fin du 19e
siècle et au début du 20e siècle
environ cent mille juifs européens pour
mettre ses terres en valeur donc avait
déjà une communauté argentine juive
d'origine européenne à laquelle des gens
comme l'âge d'or ont pu s'intégrer
parfaitement où un grand écrivain comme
stefan zweig qui a fui la seconde guerre
mondiale pour aller se réfugier en
argentine même si il s'est
malheureusement celui-ci stéphane
smagghe le fameux
auteur de du joueur et chaque joueur
d'échecs la pièce de théâtre aussi
efficace de théâtre et qui est à
l'origine une nouvelle la boucle est
bouclée
mais voilà on voit bien qu'on évolue
dans ce dans ce milieu intellectuel juif
européen qui a donné tant d'écrivains
d'artistes et aussi de joueurs d'échecs
qui sont quelquefois rester en europe
quelquefois ont dû s'exiler jusqu'en
amérique du sud
c'est le c'est le cas de migraine d'un
jeune âge d'or enfin un milieu l'âge
d'or alors un joueur qui a donc
ferrailler avec avec les plus grands
avec évidemment les espaces qu'ils
aillent fichier ravec petrossian egli
goerig hergott et un joueur d'attaqué
c'est pas du tout un joueur défensif à
la petrossian au labo de vigny que non
non c'est un joueur qui aimait beaucoup
les grandes attaques et quand il jouait
face à d'autres joueurs à da taxe a fait
feu d'artifice exceptionnel est parti
d'un jour sont souvent sommes très bien
en général oui elles sont elles sont
très tendues s'en est parti très
offensive
il allait remporter de nombreux tournois
même s'il n'a pas eu l'occasion de
réellement disputer le titre mondial
il a remporté de très nombreux tournois
notamment dans les années 40 et 50 où il
a remporté des tournois amsterdam blais
venise
bien qu'il ait eu la nationalité
argentine il a fait une grande partie de
sa carrière en europe
comme la plupart des la plupart des jo
elle a aussi gagné à barcelone à prague
la gagner de très très nombreux tournois
s'est illustré aussi par sa longévité
puisque la partie que l'on va voir
contre fischer il l'a disputé alors
qu'il avait déjà 56 ans et qu'il a joué
jusqu'à jusqu'à sa mort
jusque dans les années 90 tout à fait
alors on va voir quelques photos
historiques relatives à miguel nage
dehors donc ici c'est dans cette
première photo est bien en noir et blanc
en mai elle et elle est symptomatique à
plus deux titres un bon mais parce qu'il
ya michael deister dessus alors il est
au centre c'est celui qui est devant
juste à droite de l'homme ou par dessus
au premier rang et il est dans un club
argentin
oui parce qu'il a entrepris une tournée
des clubs argental c'est une photo de
donc il vient de s'exiler en argentine
et puis ils jouent à cordoba rosario mar
del plata il joue partout et il fait là
tu peux la tournée des clubs et on voit
que ça attire un public assez nombreux
puisque c'est un joueur très connu
ouais donc une belle photo de famille de
l'époque argentine de buenos aires
l'argentine qui était à l'époque un des
pays les plus les plus riches du monde
il faut rappeler qu'en 1948 le pib de
l'argentine dépasse celui du royaume uni
parce que c'est un pays qui a bénéficié
si l'on peut dire des deux guerres
mondiales et un gros producteur
notamment de
de bétail et de céréales oui et qui a
été à l'abri de toutes les destructions
des deux guerres mondiales
voilà cette photo des joueurs d'échecs
argentin accueillant miel neige dehors
ici au centre alors une autre
photographie ici alors on voit tu
parlais de cette fameuse simultanée là
contre 40 jours c'était plus et
peut-être celle là sa lettre est un peu
postérieur 22 postérieur donc là on voit
les joueurs c'est typique des
simultanées vous voyez que miguel
d'altorf ont fait étape est à gauche
debout et il passe des fichiers en
échiquier face à alors ici on en voit
qu'une partie mais il ya déjà eu trois
une quinzaine de jours déjà
il doit y avoir du monde parce qu'ils
sont quand même relativement serré donc
il doit y avoir beaucoup de monde à
caser dans la salle puis aussi des
spectateurs autour qui se marient se
régale du spectacle il ya toujours les
spectateurs d'arrière qui sont parfois
des souffleurs leur foi qui aide les
joueurs à s'en sortir mais ils iraient
que jamais et l'a donc peut-être qu'il
ya dans cette simultanée miguel n'a
georges joue peut-être trente quarante
cinquante partis peu importe
face à des joueurs de club donc qui ont
ainsi la possibilité de jouer face à un
grand maître ski para sinon qu'ils
restent une quelque chose de trop rares
malheureusement et mais c'est pas facile
d'aller jouer un tournoi pour rencontrer
un grand m
il faut quand même marqué des points oui
c'est pas évident mais là c'est la
possibilité de jouer une partie contre
un grand maître ici en l'occurrence
miguel nuages noirs en simultané et
probablement l'argentine donc non en
italie en italie l'italie l'argentine ya
des liens entre bruxelles et louvain
forte communauté italienne d'accord en
italie c'est l'argentine on est sûr de
l'origine oui en 1955 c'est un peu après
la guerre d'accord à l'époque où nagent
dorff écumait beaucoup les tournois
européens ayant remporté de très
nombreux
alors après un document qu'on va voir un
document historique exceptionnel alors
voilà je sais pas si vous la voyez bien
sur votre écran ou de votre téléviseur
cette feuille de partie en fait de la
19e
olympiades d'échecs apparemment ses
écrits 19 chez rares olympiens est alors
avec les blancs bobby fischer le grand
le très très grand le génie le joueur du
siècle bobby fischer usa évidemment et
miguel l'âge d'or d'argent et in voilà
la partie alors noté par fisher celle là
avec une notation très très particulière
au delà du fait qu'il écrit de façon peu
lisible ouais c'est une notation qui est
difficile à suivre pour nous oui parce
que c'est là c'est la notation anglaise
la fameuse dotation qui était
complètement
bref c'est ça c'est quand même parce que
tu ne la comprends pas non mais les
anglais avec avec leur unité de mesure
avec leur douleur leur barils leur pied
leurs miles et puis leur notation allard
notation spéciale pour les échecs et
bien ça nous désorienter les oriente un
peu le reste du monde avec ça bref mais
alors c'est notre firme essais signés
par les deux joueurs donc la signature
de fisher de la même couleur que la
partie à la fin à droite et puis la
signature de nage des enfants violés
apparemment ici voilà en tout cas un
document qui montre que les joueurs vont
se rencontrer puis plus d'une fois a
bien sûr et c'est pas toujours fischer
qui l'a emporté et voilà ici le grand
miguel l'âge d'or enfin avant un peu
plus âgés on revient un peu plus de
bedaine aussi est en train de regarder
une partie en train de voir une analyse
peut-être une analyse de joueurs en tout
cas ils jettent un oeil attentif
ce qui est certain c'est que j'ai parlé
de sa longévité
son dernier grand résultat en tournoi
c'était à 69 ans puisqu'il termine
deuxième derrière bent larsen dans un
grand tournoi donc à 69 ans il était
encore très vive d'esprit était connu
pour sa vivacité d'esprit pour ses
traits d'humour aussi
notamment dit quand boris paix ce qui
vous donne une pièce c'est que vous
allez perdre la partie quand michael
talent vous vous donne une pièce prenez
là il va peut-être vous en donner une
deuxième avec talent avait tendance à
faire beaucoup de sacrifices eux pas
toujours justifiées mais très difficile
à réfuter
voilà mes grands joueurs talent puisque
cornet qui a obtenu le titre en lui
dominati de shooting il n'a pas gardé
longtemps mais il a eu et n'a pas
beaucoup qu'ils ont eue alors bref
maintenant on revient à miguel d'âge
d'or puisque on va voir maintenant une
partie est une belle partie de mygales
nage nov et pas contre n'importe qui
puisque ça va être une partie face au
très grand bobby fischer aurait moins
que bobby fischer et laure pas n'importe
quelle époque on né en 1966 donc ça veut
dire que la fischer est quasiment au
sommet de son art parce qu'il aurait
déjà sans doute pu être champion du
monde des 66 il a refusé en fait de
jouer le cycle parce que les règles ne
lui plaisait pas c'était des tournois on
y roule et un match ils voulaient des
matches pour se qualifier aussi est il
devenu finalement chaplin de 4,72
mais il aurait pu l'être plutôt bref
enfin tout cas fischer est au top en 66
si la vente presque quel âge il doit
vendre trois ans par exemple 7e 23 ans
voilà la jeune kasparov est devenu
champion du monde donc c'est tout dire
et miliana geoffrey un peu plus âgées
puisqu'il a presque seulement 2,6 et ça
il a 56 ans à ce moment là donc c'est un
âge canonique pour un joueur d'échecs
déjà voilà donc on va voir comment le
vieux briscard nage dehors ce magnifique
joueur va jouer une très belle partie
face à ce qui allait devenir un des
champions moules aux championnes ont
sans doute le plus le plus
médiatique de toute l'histoire du jeu
d'échecs de très très loin mais bobby
fischer et miliana jorf a eu la chance
le privilège de jouer plein de partie
face à bruguières dans celle ci qui
n'est pas la moindre
c'est parti avec le coup des quatre
d'entrée en matière alors fichiers
répond par kiev 6
alors c'est typique du style fischer
puisqu'après ckg 6/4 laissé trois fous
g7 on est rentré dans une estonienne
alors l'affiché hier à doris un il jouer
tout le temps
l'estonienne qui est une défense contre
le pion dame extrêmement agressive ou
les noirs jouent bas pour mater pour
mater les bleus en fait un et c'est pas
c'est pas une ouverture pour faire pour
faire moulin c'est soit on mate
soit on est matée c'est à dire c'est une
ouverture vraiment dans le site de
fisher tout pour l'attack donc eu quatre
on était les blancs on laisse les blancs
constituent un force entre deux pions
avec l'idée de réussir à le fixer un
moment de le bloquer et de l'attaqué par
des collatéraux comme ces cinq loups f5
exactement donc décidé on va attaquer
par ces cinq on va attaquer
éventuellement par 5 on peut attaquer
plus tard a pris pareille 5
effectivement au lieu dit au lieu
d'occuper le centre en fait on le
contrôle à distance avec les fous et on
attaque une fois qu'il est bien établi
pour le harceler afin de le faire
exploser
faux e deux nagent dans fin alors ça
c'est un coût tout à fait standard un
fou de compression nous faut deux avants
qui avaient laissé trois parce que sa
faim parce que c'est intéressant que ça
évite les problèmes mais aussi ça permet
parfois de jouer le coup à fond j'ai 5
puis d'amd 200 craindre cavaliers g4 au
soir de choses et ça c'est un coût qui
peut avoir un groupe venait mais ça on
peut rentrer dans les ventes un peu plus
standard après petit rock foo gsm
voilà on est bon niveau et auxquelles
n'ont donc là le fou ici on pêche toute
possibilité de bouger pour ce cavalier
et on peut vouloir jouer dam des deux
gros des choses comme ça hein et puis et
puis très vite attaqué en fait et le
foulard empêche
en fait on va prendre si ça bouge ça pro
comprend on peut jouer trois ans après
derrière avec une grosse position d'
attaque rapide il faut être présent ce
type d'opération c5 et une bonne
traction sa bonne réaction quand on met
la pression sur une aile il faut réagir
au centre de toute façon ses idées
noires il fallait le faire mais vous
voyez pas aux 5 parce que le fouet la
haye et c'est embêtant voilà si on joue
si on joue au 5 et bien on saute on
saute au cloud auto clouage c'est un
autre club
on n'a pas trop envie de faire donc on
joue plutôt c5 à noter on peut jouer à 6
mai sur ce genre de coups et dans ce cas
là le four revient de trois et on n'a
pas peur de cavaliers cas puisqu'on a le
fou voilà voilà ensuite on pourra jouer
en d2 avec gain de temps puisque le pion
à chis sera attaqué c'est ça ben c'est
toute l'idée cette manoeuvre qui est
subtil c'est des petits coups comme ça
c'est sec
bon donc la contre attaque alors à noter
que si ben ça bouge ici ça ici on peut
alors si les blancs prennent on peut
presque joué des coups comme damas un
coût d'un v6 parce que toutes les cases
noires sont en l'air le fouillis
réveiller on sacrifie carrément un pion
et puis on risque démolir toutes les
cases noires du côté de la halle dame
donc c'est vraiment un début qu'il faut
prendre avec précaution donc des cinqs
effectivement une bonne réaction on
évite d'ouvrir le jeu
on joue des 5 avec constitution de la
fameuse peut-être plutôt un jour f3 avec
la fameuse chaîne audio c'est solide
on a mis la pression dans le camp noir
c'est très bien alors maintenant e6
maintenant que la chaîne d'opium ont été
stabilisées on joue aussi
l'idée est la suivante c'est de prendre
en d5 bien sûr et puis de profiter de la
colonne est ouverte pour commande pour
faire un peu de pression sur la colonne
ou plus tard si ce fou on arrive à le
débloquer on aura une éventuelle case
ici soutenu par la tour pour la
pénétration notamment du cavaly de cases
noires un jour de 600 se ménage aussi
toute la diagonale pour le front de
casse morin alors que si on joue aux
cinq ans on bouchain alors qu à bf3
seller maintenant sur le cavalier ne
vaut mieux pas vaut mieux pas laisser le
roi au centre parce que comme ça se
présentait des choses que le centre
s'ouvre voilà alors c'est bon moment
maintenant pour plaire ya trois de
juhasz 6 parce que si on joue à six
maintenant le couffo trois seraient
entre guillemets puni par cas les g4 qui
gagne autant sur le fou et c'est pas si
jamais agréable de le voir jouer le coup
le fou plusieurs fois surtout qu'on ne
saurait pas trop où le mettre on se
marie cavallier g4 ils sont obligés de
revenir en c1 probablement ça arrive
il ya des parties il faut renier ans et
reims ne s'écrit pas ce qui n'est pas
forcément agréable alors fouache 4 qui
est l'autre coup on n'échange pas le fou
quand un cavalier sur deux questions
surtout dans une position qui te
s'ouvrir ici avec des fous trop
dangereux non enfouis h 4 si les noirs
rouges et 5 c'est possible mais on
affaiblit beaucoup son rock
après coup j'ai 3 il faudra y aura
sûrement h4 attend plus que les blancs
n'ont pas encore fait le petit rock donc
un sont libres de mener une attaque très
rapide à ce moment là sur les droits
voilà exactement qu'il faut pas trop
harceler le fou comme ça 6
on ne veut pas se prendre une attaque
avec des pions trop avancé si vous
avancez vos pions vous donnez une cible
à l'adversaire donc réfléchissez y de
vous deux fois et assurez vous que c'est
bien jouable que ça correspond bien à
votre signe de jeu donc pris deux ans
des 5e prend des 5 et l'asse prend des 5
alors précis mais on prend du plomb
s'est il vaut mieux avoir deux pions au
centre bon là en l'occurrence c'est tout
à fait jouable parce que le pion au cas
très bien protégé par le câble et ses 3
on peut encore mettre la dame ces deux
aussi en protection il n'y a pas de
clouage possible sur la colonne puisque
le fou ici protège l'euro a déjà donc ya
pas de problème pour essayer de tenir
ses pions au centre alors à noter la
manoeuvre aussi classique ça va être de
jouer ce cavalier en d2 qui surprotègent
le pire le 4 alors on va voir ça à
prêcher cinq mondes choisi d'affaiblir
un peu ici fischer son est le roi il
n'aime pas trop cette position faut dire
que c'est cette ouverture est un peu une
arme anti fischer parce que c'est pas
forcément exactement le l'ordre de coups
ni la position que fisher le mieux donc
il est un peu oublié de jouer peut-être
un peu contre nature il se couchait 5
alors fou g3 ici alors le fou est bien
parce qu'il est absurde et si ce qu'est
ce qu'on appelle un pion à rien puis on
s'est un peu arriérés et bien sûr alors
il convient de pions blancs devant ce
n'est pas très grave mais met une petite
pression a noté que la manoeuvre que
j'ai cité tous leurs qualités 2d fois
avec cavalli c4 ça augmente la pression
avec le fou sur le pion et c'est parfois
difficile à défendre voire impossible
donc il faut il ya des plaines manoeuvre
pourra tirer parti de cette petite
faiblesse ici donc b5 alors qu'au
naturel
c'est typique alors on voit ça aussi
dans ce qu'on appelle le gambit
bennecourt
dans une autre d'un autre type
d'ouverture alors l'idée de beyssac elle
et qu'on peut pas prendre en fait parce
que imaginant si on prend du cavalier
évidemment on laisse le pied 1 400
protection maintenant que le fou n'est
plus en train de clore cavaliers le pion
4 est pris et si on prend du fou ou deux
mais on a un vrai souci parce que quand
il prend la 4 quand même pourquoi parce
que là ça y est et le clouage est
possible attention donc loin j'ai
possible donc ici par exemple pour fêter
à l'épreuve 1,4 alors 38 yahia le 25
janvier aussi damas cinq échecs tout
simplement et c'est vrai que c'est pour
moi le clouage que damas cinq échecs ici
le cavalier peut pas revenir en sait
trop puisqu'on a le fou fou j'ai cette
voie la sica a laissé trois simplement
fait fou prend échec qui on prend dans
prend et on a gagné une pièce il ya un
pion un pion mais en plus on a un gros
centre qui veut plus rock et on peut pas
invoquer un regard donc la preuve le
prochain coup ça t'aurait 8 avec un roi
qui sont obligés d'aller se balader et
on peut dire que les noirs un gros
avantage de ce fait oui suivi de dôme b2
par exemple chose comme ça deux enfants
tout cas et coralie et lamoise eh oui
bref fini non mais ça va être assez déjà
aussi déjà extrêmement pénible en fait
mais la dame était super bien placé ici
bien sûr donc sur des scènes qu'on peut
pas prendre ni par le fou ni par le
cavalier dans les deux cas il ya
toujours des c'est une manoeuvre
importante à retenir parce que ça permet
quand même de gagner du temps au lieu de
préparer lentement
cette manoeuvre par à 6 puis b5 qui
laisserait trop de temps au gland pour
s'organiser
il faut jouer là on joue très vite on
garde l'initiative ou en tout cas on
essaye de l'arraché et c'est ce qui
permet à fischer ii
de continuer à jouer dans la partie et
appels et ses initiatives aux blancs
voient la presse aussi bien pour les
noirs parce que les blancs par ok c'est
bien mais les blancs tiennent bien alors
à noter qu'après cavaliers d2 on peut
plus bouger le cas mais ça me fout et
alors c'est ce que je disais c'est que
ce cavalier alors il est bien parce
qu'il attaque
enfin il protège le 4 et maintenant il
ya une menace de prendre des cinq cibles
et 5 saute la casse et 4 est faible et
ce cavalier plus tard pour a sauté sur
l'occasion
4 et puis demander si ce sera perdu il
sera en tout cas sous pression faudra
jouer des gros points faibles comme
cavalier vite des choses comme ça donc
ça c'est pas c'est pas agréable donc
fischer se résout ici à jouer alors
surtout pas b4 vous avez compris parce
que si vous jouez b4 vous affaiblissez
la case c4 on va pouvoir y sauter dessus
donc on va pas jouer bekaert en tout cas
pas tout de suite on va jouer à 6 on
joue à six et un joint à 6 on protège
des 5 et donc on protège ses quatre
voilà donc petit rock c'est leur promet
blanc tours 8
alors très important pour 8 crée une
menace fischer imier jouer des coups qui
force le verser à répondre la menace
c'est quoi un bep maintenance et b4
quand même parce que si lecavalier vient
jouer le camel le pion n'est défendue
que par une pièce et il attaqué par deux
lecavalier 6 + 1 tour 8
ça me garderai une pion central et alors
là c'est une catastrophe oui parce qu'il
ya des choses que deuxième tombe dans la
foulée donc il fait chaud il va aller ça
c'est hors de question de laisser faire
ça donc dans ces deux voies la dame ces
deux très bons coups je finis mon
développement
la dame est sortie les tours sont
connectés j'ai fait le roc 1 2 3 4
pièces sorties les blancs ont fini leur
développement
on surprotège le pion le cas tout va
bien pour les blancs d'oeufs puis on
sent trop bien placé un fou qui tape sur
la faiblesse noir tout va bien les noirs
de l'autre côté ne sont pas non plus
démunis ils ont une bonne partie aussi
ils ont fini leur de l'europe
ils ont deux pièces sorties une tour
active bon
reste encore deux pièces ici à sortir
peut-être et trouver une case pour la
dame tout un peu de retard développement
mais avec une belle espace à l'aide
d'armes pour l'instant on peut pas dire
grand chose alors le suivant de fichiers
un peu peut se questionner si c'était
peut-être le alors il ya des façons
d'activer les tours on peut faire des
choses que le tour à 16.7 suivi de
recette par exemple faire toi cette
recette pour augmenter la pression sur
quatre c'est tout à fait envisageable
et c'est une façon active et une tour
qui sinon on a du mal à trouver sa place
regardez alors que celle-ci il suffit de
ramener celle là ici et puis ça y est
elles sont actives ont envisagé des f4
plus tard pourquoi pas on peut essayer
d'attaquer le rock il ya quand même ici
il ya un point d'ouverture et on peut
jouer sur la colonne fo si donc la fiche
avoue le ku'damm 7
moi j'aime pas trop ce coup parce que
dans le set ça ça alors ça peut
permettre de connecter les tours à terme
par exemple pourrait envisager de l'état
d'hawaï fuite pourquoi pas mais attaquer
un pion mettant la dame demande on l'a
déjà dit que leur fort sur des modèles
tv vaut mieux éviter l'attaqué avec la
pièce la plus lourde
oui je voudrais me avoir la tour de main
et la dame derrière parce que c'est
quand même la pièce la plus longue qui
est le plus en danger ces saletés devant
que le plus en danger
donc la puce la plus lourde celle qui
vous le plus de points on a essayé
d'éviter de mettre en danger quand même
un bon puis c'est quand même le jeu des
rois donc la dame est censé rester
derrière les tours pas devant alors
temps de prendre des risques en général
savez on s'aventure comme tel et sur un
peu plus de soin où elle m'a
effectivement et la b en alphabet avoir
dans le coup que j'ai cités pouf
et puis là on n'aime pas ça vis-à-vis
tour dames c'est quand même très
désagréable pour ça que ce coût des
recettes il est quand même le pion le
pion aux 4 et de fêtes imprenable ans
ouais alors il est peut-être nécessaire
parce que fisher voulait jouer le coup
suivant quelle alors où la dame c'est
toi
il voulait jouer qui avait levé 17 si la
dame était resté là le problème c'était
la faiblesse du pion dévoile donc en
fait il a joué dans le sel pour protéger
des six afin de jouer cavalier les sept
bons c'est un peu lourd
c'est un peu vous il ya il a rien trouvé
de mieux bon ceci dit ce n'est pas
claire parce que c'est pas simple parce
que les cavaliers 8 où il va il peut pas
là
ces six peut pas les rats 6 obligé de
passer par 17 donc il fallait trouver un
moyen mais ce qui est vraiment c'était
c'est vraiment ça paraît quand même un
peu pataud j'ai envie de dire dangereux
donc à quatre alors ça très bon coup de
nage de off alors l'idée d'un cas très
simple c'est de perturber la chaîne de
pions noirs de l'album surtout d'essayer
de puisqu'il n'ya pas d'avant poste
naturel pour le cavalier en c4
s'il existe pas mais il faut le créer
donc il suffit que si les noirs prennent
le pion si on prend par exemple pour
rien mais si j'ai tout de suite
d'ailleurs un cavalier c400 réfléchir
pousser son attaque des jeunes qui ont
des six sur dix est indéfendable et
indéfendable façonner la partie devient
plus que compliqué donc l'option est
imprenable
je croyais pas ce que et sokal c4 alors
c'est le pion des sites vont beaucoup
plus loin quatre super content quand on
veut des vous amis il faut pas perdre de
points alors de temps pardon à l'europe
rennes il faut tout de suite aller
attaquer des six
à noter que la prise en d3 seraient
punis par simplement fou détroit et le
clouage tour dames fait que lecavalier 4
serait totalement perdue donc le coca
très très fort et sa force la réponse
les quatre parce qu'il faut sortir bien
sûr on donne la casa 4 mais au moins on
gagne le temps ça oblige le cavaly c3
jouer oui et puis il faut bien faire
quelque chose avec le pion parce qu'il
est attaqué trois fois quand même le
pion bessin qu'il était attaqué trois
fois il fallait faire quelque chose mais
c'est mieux que de prendre parce que
prendrait pas de menaces là et comme une
menace de france donc ce cas et c'est
quand on prend moins une gagné une pièce
c'est quand même énorme donc aller des 1
donc un acheteur se laisse pas bien sûr
avoir il faut qu'à valider un il ya
encore une fois y'a pas de bruit menace
ici puisque fou détroit et le cavaly
free cloud et assure la dame et surtout
le problème c'est que à terme c'est
l'affaiblissement de la case c4 avec
l'affaiblissement du pion des six
derrière ce qu'on entrevoit aussi avec
cavaliers d1 qui est un coup de retrait
qui avait pas si passifs que ça parce
que via e3 et bien ce deuxième cavalier
lui aussi va pouvoir viser la case de
quatre c4 arrive à viser aussi à la
caisse f5 qui est quand même très
intéressante
ça fait deux cases magnifique de
pénétration pour ce cavalier ce qui peut
sauter ici par deux cases de pénétration
n'ont pas encore bougé 5 me sur pour
contrôler avec le fou mais il y aura
l'autre ça fait beaucoup
bon donc cavalier de 5 de la part
maintenant de bobby fischer bon alors en
jours camaïeu 5
il bouge toute action des pièces lourdes
sur e4 même pas de quelques affaires
pour dire que ça c'est protéger ses
protégés évidemment dans l'intérêt de
curieux 5 il est double 1
je contrôle f5 par le fouet deux jeux
contrôle aussi c4 donc en cas de
caresser 4 je prends et le fou la dame
qui reprend hockey et ça c'est moins
gênante
une pièce ici qu'ils soient qu'ici c'est
un fou une dame qui est là j'attaque pas
la faiblesse
par contre nage dehors évidemment montre
toute la maestria de son développement
ici puisqu'il à ce fameux maintenant tu
parlais de 3 et l'armée en a deux ce que
fait que s'il y en a un qui sautent ici
l'autre peut le remplacer en cas dé
change donc c'est fort on peut dire que
la nage dorff a réussi à trouver un
développement idéal pour toutes ces
pièces c'est très très bien donc avalé
g6 l'afficheur bombe elle se rend compte
qu'il peut pas faire grand chose contre
l'invasion ses cadres dont qui joue
cavalier g6 avec l'idée que angers 6e
qu'elle peut venir en f4 et donc bloquer
l'action du fou il n'a pas le choix si
ça ça saute
la partie est finie vous avez deux pions
quasiment passées au centre qui vont
pousser ça va créer des merciers normes
jouer aussi s'en va éclater le pion à
vii ici et le roi sera totalement à sec
avec un pion passé en plus un vain mot
c'est l'horreur c'est cela le pion des
six tiens tiens toutes les positions
noir là il faut surtout pas qu'ils se
pions tombe donc cavalier c4 donc la
menace de prendre des six est très forte
on peut pas défendre des six mais elle
est mal placée et stoneham
la limite presque en coupe même tout et
suit est pas possible c'est pas sinon
moi ça tiendrait le pion mais on peut
passer de deux pièces mineurs qui
attaquent on ne peut pas défendre avec
la dame ne va pas donner la dame contre
une pièce mineur sur deux questions
de la même façon de défendre avec tour
des huit est possible alors c'est
possible alors qu'est ce que c'est
extrêmement passif on puisse à se
heurter à des cavaliers des six qui a
peut-être là pour capitale
mais on aurait de toute façon une tour
une dame qui défendent contre ont tourné
un cavalier est un fou ben oui c'est
vous imaginez ça fait 15 kw est
immobilisé pour pour six dates ac 3 3 6
6 points en attaque et 15 points
d'immobiliser sa phase afin différentiel
de 5
c'est l'heure pas installé il ya cinq
points qui vont pouvoir attaquer
ailleurs ça fait cher quand même hein ça
fait cher le
défense donc cavalier hausse et quatre
bombes un câble f4 l'aca ses actifs
on n'est que trois poules en dépenses en
dépenses en défense on est français on
dépense moyenne demandé les deux bon là
ça bouche l'action du fou g3 évidemment
qu'il n'attaque plus des 6 mans ce
cavalier bien placés en plus on peut
envisager maintenant ça peut ça peut
permettre de recycler les forces noires
maintenant pour mieux protéger ça il ya
pas d opérations d'attendre puisque le
joueur peut le prendre tout de suite oui
je pense que les blancs n'ont pas envie
de perdre le fou eux deux parce que si
on ne va rien comme cavalier pour deux
tours prend on aurait de fuji 4 par
exemple oui pour forcera f3 et puis on
aurait à ce moment-là peut-être un fou
des quatre échecs des choses un petit
peu désagréable c'est possible tout à
fait puis on prend s4 est là surtout bon
on a un pion fait non plus maintenant
c'est repos non seulement il ya toujours
ce qu'ils ont appelé faible quand même
une attaque permanente dessus il faut
quand même donc pour l'instant la dame
sakho reste là ou alors faudrait
remplacer la dame dans une autre pièce
pour garder supions mais ça ça devient
pas terrible comment je protège ta parce
qu'ils imaginent qu'ils ont un plan un
plan simple à base de ces pas d'âme des
trois dames et froid mais comment je
fais comment je protège ta mais je peux
pas simplement
donc c'est simple choix donc bay trouve
encore mieux nash d'offres superbe aulas
et ses magnifiques à la suite faites
vous la main aux cinq superbes
c'est stratégiquement très très fort
c'est très très fort alors il est de 5
est simple mais j'attaque ça vraiment
sam nascar et pendez s'ils s'attaquent à
tout bon c'est l'horreur et a pris la
prise qui forçait le voir mais on a ce
qu'on appelle un pion un pion passé
passé qui en plus dans son sillage va
laisser d'éventuels gaz pour les pour
les pièces blanches en mairie on pense
tout de suite à la diagonale f3
oui c'est bien sûr on a envie de doubler
ça parce que si après on menace des six
qui attaquent la dame et le la tour est
perdu
pour le pion qu'on a là de toute façon
si on joue fosse 3 il est quasiment
bloqué puis peut pas avancer
ouais ça fait peur parce qu'il va
falloir s'immobiliser ici si on arrive à
pousser la dame va être perturbée où
elle va et puis le pion c5 est faible
débit possible pour l'instant ils
étaient des fils était défendu par le
pion si je vous des six est plus
défendue par rien non et donc il ne peut
pas choisir n'importe quelqu'un si elle
va en 17 et une fourchette calais b avec
cavaliers b si c'est vrai ça va très
vite et si on va aussi son peut avoir
des cavaliers detroit simplement et je
peux rien faire contre cavaliers pendant
ces 5 quasiment bref on va voir ce qui
se passe ou f3 tout simplement fou versa
et concrète va menace des six attaques
les dames et plouf plouf ici là tout est
prise
donc dans les fuites ça fait ça fait
pitié
alors là mais fuite mais il n'y a pas de
menace d'attaquer la dame un accord mais
bon on a enjoint faust rendre plus on
assure contrôler la case 4 ce qui rend
ce pion aux scènes totalement inefficace
et en plus le cas mais il va pendant 5
voilà maintenant le problème est là
c'est que ça on récupère le pion on peut
déjà dire que la partie est
stratégiquement foutu en deux coups
l'âge d'or enfin montré que sa position
était déjà écrasante il avait déjà
toutes les pièces développer un toutes
les pièces mineurs ont été développés la
dame était sorti on l'avait dit tout à
l'heure les tours étaient connectés et
puis pour les stars on a tendance à sa
joue pas ça ça joue pas ça pour
l'instant ça rien démontré et puis
maintenant que ça ça a sauté mais ça
c'est faible
ça c'est faible l'opposition est quand
même et le temps lambeaux aux clients de
passer là c'est extrêmement difficile
donc à moins d'un miracle
la position est déjà stratégiquement
perdu foot bessette de fisher alors ici
contre attaque à la menace est quand
même de prendre le pion des cinq un
défenseur tout simplement
ici ils se pressent pas notre ami
georges puisqu'il joue le simple
cavaliers c4 alors qu a laissé 4 qu'est
ce qui se passe sur calais c4 alors il
ya des menaces qu'elle épaississe
attaque et peut protéger banque si on
fait fou prend ce pas clair
ce qui se passe au cas des six il peut y
avoir aussi sur cavaliers prend de
l'autre côté là il ya un cavalier en
n'ont pas déçu cependant puis les ventes
et camélidés 7 par exemple
taipei a décalé 17,6 on va voir on va
essayer d'étudier les prises parce qu'il
ya quand même pris dissidents même prix
alors étudiant simplement d'abord fou
prend des cinq qui est quand même l'idée
est bien simplement une forêt fou prenez
cinq câbles et prendre des 5 et qui a
validé cette par exemple par exemple ou
des coups comme aussi il ya des scènes
aussi mince enseigne que la dame parce
qu'on peut échanger tous ces gars ne pas
la dame presque si quand même parce que
si si tout reprend tour wilson in quand
même la banque peut quand même prendre
la dame nous prend la dalle et puis
simplement tout reprend échec
intermédiaire reprend mais après je suis
pas mort apprend tellement énorme pour
repas mais on a quand même dame contre
dans les cavaliers ça fait le cabinet
contre les cavaliers puis on adam contre
tours est fou et puis on peut même jouer
cavalier b6 qui est le recteur et on
peut jouer aussi qu'avec les v6 puisque
ça fait fourchette tour cavaliers et si
lecavalier prend dame prend échec et on
récupère le cavalier en ayant mangé un
pion au passage la dame est supérieur à
tour est fou et comme il ya suffisamment
de pionsat suffit pour avoir un gros
avantage en finale c'est très gros
avantage blanc ici on est donc faux
bessette donc ça c'était après call des
sicap magnifique puisqu'il donne le pion
la neige drogue
sont pas les options passé l'entreprise
serait cavalier l'entreprise ça serait
cavalier prend kamal et prend des 5
et que se passe-t-il sur cavaliers -
dix-sept fois on peut jouer cavalier 17
direct on peut jouer mais c'est tout de
suite et ça donne à peu près la même
chose c'est pareil la dame est foutu
c'est à dire si on fait tout reprendre
eh bien on pourrait on prend la dame la
dame pouvait pas demander si lecavalier
nation maintenant on prend la dame et
après tout reprend un échec pour
apprendre et ici par exemple 3 pour
subir j'aime bien moins on va prendre on
va prendre mais simplement on peut jouer
au oui il se prend à rêver si c'est
encore mieux kahveci c'est fort parce
que s'attaque le fou on est obligé de
venir à ces six parce qu'il faut garder
un oeil sur ça et l'arrêt dame prend ces
menaces déchets qu'elle découvre la tacc
le fou attaque le cavalier menace des
chèques à la découverte
on aurait pu prendre tout à l'heure du
du fou hein
mais bon si on avait pris du même si on
prend du fou ici toute façon il faut
prendre des 5 et cavaliers b6 c'est très
embêtant aussi oui mon peugeot tour des
huit pour le tour des huit meilleurs et
encore mieux je pense tous à tous la
même scène où va le cavalier sachant
qu'on a toujours un échec
donc on ne peut pas contre attaqué comme
çà
si j'attaque la dame je fais d'abord
échec et après je prends le fou donc là
d'un médecin comme enjeu je protège le
cavalier si je joue ton des huit quand
le tour des huit qui protège ici où
apparemment de protéger leurs gardes
pouf carrier 5 et comment je protège
d'un premier set mais je ne peux pas je
peux pas jouer tourner cet oxymore
encore une fois c'est bon bien sûr m6
suffit pas parce que d'obliger six
échecs de suite cavaliers de cette manne
way réussissent effectivement j'ai dans
mes chèques
c est enfin c'est l'horreur bref donc
faut le voir parce que ça veut dire
qu'ils jouent à un coût actifs
il n'a pas peur de laisser le pur
entreprises parce que toutes les prises
perdant fait donc c'est très dur pour
les noirs tour à des 8
fischer a vu tout ça bien sûr donc ils
jouent tour à des 8 il augmente la
pression sur le dessin d'hergé peut-être
quand même arrivé à manger ce pion
silenor a réuni en gestion il pourrait y
avoir des espoirs de s'en sortir mais
s'est pas fait c'est pas fait alors des
cons c'est chez nokia est fait mais
aussi celles qui s'annoncent et ça peut
pas bouger ça c'est pas mobile bref
alors très jolis coups suivants
maintenant de l'âge d'or est signalé ces
six ça c'est joli c'est joli cas les c6
regarder et j'attaque évidemment la
qualité qui en dépendent
on trouve ça c'est un désastre il faut
éviter lisant et en cas de prise du fou
je peux prendre là et j'ai toujours le
fou qui pendent contrôler le pion qui
est toujours pas ses protégés et il
reste toujours plein de menaces
on peut après envisager de simplement de
peu d'autres c'est le plus beau penser
je veux cavaliers b6 pour accompagner le
pion jusqu'à la promotion et obliger les
noirs entre du matériel en échange des
pions on a donné du matériel perdre du
matériel alors si les noirs ici tenter
calais pour des scènes qui permet la
qualité triplement par la qualité donc
il est tout reprendre d'abord tout
reprend demain donc ça c'est un échange
standard dès maintenant pour huit mois
là il faut pas perdre de temps pourquoi
entreprendre tours 8
on évite la perte ici de la qualité est
là au regard des très jolies neige
dehors ok mais maintenant tout un tas
mais je veux pousser moi je veux pousser
est allé jusqu'à damas noter que toutes
les cases sont protégés la tour ici et
en défense donc c'est une tour qui est
derrière en qui ont passé c'est mortel
d'exception avance en plus le clou on
s'essaye n'est plus protégé à noter que
qu'en l'occurrence le cavaliere est
protégé à cause du fou donc toutes les
pièces blanches sont extrêmement active
et se protège toutes les unes les autres
c'est très difficile pour ces 8 alors
tous ces huit empêche la plus est
puisque cette fois on peut prendre le
cavalier puisque la tour protège
d'accord
hé bé simplement pouf mythique où un
petit coup en fait 5 yahoo qui me
sortent deux exemples oui puisque là les
noirs n'ont plus grand chose à jouer
avec quoi faire en fait le petit conte
ici ça évite le petit matin du couloir
le roi peut s'évader
ça évite toute pénétration sur la classe
g 4 allée minus assez secondaire c'est
surtout un coup d'attentes qui montre
que les que les noirs n'ont rien qu en
fait donc il reste pour fisher a tenté
encore kabylie à 8
il veut sans doute essayer de bloquer ce
pion en venant des six mais on va
regarder tout simplement encore la suite
car elle est six à cinq attaques le foot
bessette qui ne peut pas ni alliance et
6 évidemment ni prendre dans des scènes
qui est extrêmement protégé donc il
reste que soit x 8 qui se heurtent
peut-être cavale et v6 ou à la tour si
je vais enlever 8 pouces calais 17
c'est horrible qui tombe sans compter
que je peux même prendre le fou et si la
tour prends je vous des six pouces avec
un gain de temps et je le gagne du temps
sur la tour et après 17 j'attaque le
cavalier et on peut pas empêcher la
promotion on peut empêcher la promotion
ça va être dur donc tour b 8 sur cette
position
et là coup de massue dans les cinq
pénétration dans le corps noirs ici
puisque la dame en f5 par attac la
fameuse faiblesses qu'on avait cité au
début ce pion est complètement mort je
menace pourquoi pas d'aller même filtré
en 17
mais simplement de prendre de plus en
plus de cas que font les noirs cavaliers
des six est simplement là ah oui alors
la fin et joly puisque qu'elle était si
c'est la dernière
le dernier soubresaut en quelque sorte
des noirs puisqu'après car il prend des
six ces abandons pourquoi simplement
parce que là il ya plus possibilités
regardez après une dame prend cavaliers
qui a forcé m et simplement je vous
prends le fou voilà alors qu'est ce qui
se passe et bs il est ou si la tour
prend aimerions tac échec
boum je récupère la tour et j'ai une
tour de plus un tour de plus et le pion
passé et encore l'initiative est
toujours le pion passé des attaques de
maths parce que je vois pas comment le
roi peut s'en sortir ici il y avait le
fou de 4 blanche qui est un ancien dans
son schéma temps quelques saynètes enfin
en tout cas ça gagne tout le matos
extrêmement à l'allemand elle est
magnifique ce parti c'est une des plus
belles parties d'attac sur le thème de
la de l'estonienne superbe conception
hamel dame de création d'un nouveau
poste pour le cavalier pour les
cavaliers
ce qui se sont relayés ouais ils ont
c'était une sarabande de cavaliers
au milieu de l'échiquier et fisher on a
perdu son latin c'est un argentin c'est
étrange de perdre son latin mais ouais
ouais mais c'est ce seuil c'est ça c'est
ça mais c'est cette c'est une partie
modèle parce qu'effectivement on a tout
ce jeu sur l'affaiblissement la casse et
4 le pion des six faible au fondeur
c'est une jolie le dire même en donner
on a une transposition de position vers
une sorte de benoni c'est plus tout à
fait une estonienne avec cette structure
mais bon ces procédés et ou céder ce
sont des solutions de piolenc peu
cousine est bon ça a été fait avec
maestria et à chaque fois qu'il était
possible d'augmenter la pression sans
céder à des menaces qui finalement n'en
étais pas il a il a profité de
l'occasion d'altorf il augmenter
davantage 56 ans oui quand il a en face
à un fischer kan avait 24 qui était au
summum de son de son île où l'on trouve
à 23 23 24 voilà donc je crois que là ça
ça démontre tout le talent de ce
magnifique joueur miel major polonais
puis argentin est très grands joueurs du
jeu d'échecs ayant marqué tout son
époque par sont joués par le plaisir qui
donnait à voir jouer à tous ses
admirateurs dans le monde entier merci
du rhum
ainsi stéphane pour ce petit retour
historique sur ce très grand champion il
ya une major et moi je vous dis donc
à bientôt pour une prochaine émission
diagonale t sur nos grands champions
historiques du fait des chèques au
revoir au revoir